100 billion dollars to give away i would
first remember that we live in a
democracy so I would look for the things
that democracy overlooks and those are
mainly I would say the higher things not
so much health which everybody is
concerned with and which the government
pays lots of money for but the are high
culture I would take as an example or
Andrew Carnegie's making libraries
available to small towns in America that
I think was a very well thought
contribution and something similar to
that to do the arts music and and of
course the intellect but not necessarily
the university's politically correct as
they are
you